Ronnie the robot was developed by our  team he's an artificially intelligent  Ronnie do you want to check in with him  at all I'll wheel him in if you want  Robin I'll leave it up question  intelligent it's a robot Ronnie and he  wants to show off some of his new  features maybe he's coming in on his own  hi Ronnie yes I'm going to say now that  Ronnie is intelligent I'm like a Roomba  crust with a Roomba what a Roomba cross  with an old horny prick yeah what  somebody don't understand English well  he looks real I come in peace in your  ass this is Ronnie the robot  six-point-nine does your antenna the two  dildos look like horns coming out of  your head is that the thing you put in  your ass yes that thing with a bob the  thing with the balls on it yeah is it  the future amazing  I can't wait for his next update right I  have one new feature oh look he's  turning around to show it  this is what Steve Jobs dream was we  created the world's dumbest robot